MRS.
CLINTON: Good afternoon, everyone.
(Applause.)
Well, thank you.
Thank you very much.
I have the great pleasure to introduce our
next two speakers, who are about to have a
conversation concerning health care.
And I thought hard about how to introduce
these two men.
(Laughter.)
And the more I thought about it, the more
I realized how much they have in common.
They are both left-handed.
(Laughter.)
They both love golf, a game that does not
often reciprocate the love they put into it.
(Laughter.)
They both are fanatic sports fans and go to
great lengths to be in front of the TV or
on the side of the court or the field.
They both are master politicians.
Each of them has only lost one election.
(Laughter.)
They are both Democrats.
They have fabulous daughters.
(Laughter.)
They each married far above themselves.
(Laughter and applause.)
And they each love our country.
And so please join me in welcoming Number
42 and Number 44, Bill Clinton and President
Barack Obama.
(Applause.)
PRESIDENT OBAMA: Mr. President.
(Laughter.)
PRESIDENT CLINTON: Are you interviewing me?
PRESIDENT OBAMA: That would be bad.
I've been talking a lot today.
PRESIDENT CLINTON: I want to thank you for
giving Hillary a job.
That was a good thing you did.
(Laughter.)
Thank you for coming.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: Well, it is wonderful to
be back.
And let me start just by saying to all the
people who have for years now supported the
incredible efforts of CGI, thank you.
Because wherever we travel, all across the
globe, we see the impact that it's making
every single day.
And we're very proud of what you all do.
And let me say that we still miss our former
Secretary of State.
(Applause.)
And I should add that there's nothing she
said that was not true, particularly the part
about us marrying up.
(Laughter.)
PRESIDENT CLINTON: Well, that brings me to
my first health care comment.
This is going to be a conversation about domestic
and international health, and America's role
in it.
But I want to begin by telling you that I
think the First Lady has done a great job
in this fight against childhood obesity.
We have been honored at our foundation to
be asked to represent her effort in 18,000
schools where we've lowered the calories in
drinks being served in schools by 90 percent.
But she has been great on that one.
The other thing I think is that I was a little
upset -- and, as you know, called one of your
administration members when you got to Africa
-- when I read an article that said that you
didn't have a big initiative in Africa.
And I said -- I can't say exactly what I said
-- (laughter) -- but I said that is inaccurate.
(Laughter.)
That's the sanitized version of what I said.
Because when the President took office, our
program, begun under President Bush, PEPFAR,
was giving antiretroviral medicine to 1.7
million people.
Because of an agreement that I made with President
Bush to use generic drugs that were approved
by the FDA, about half our drugs were being
purchased in that way.
Under President Obama, we've gone to 99 percent.
We are treating more than 5.1 million, three
times as many for less money.
(Applause.)
That is a stunning legacy -- so that more
money has been put into malaria medicine,
bed nets, so you saved a lot of money and
saved more lives while doing it.
And I'm very proud of that.
And I want to thank you for it.
It's important.
(Applause.)
Now, maybe at the end of this conversation
we can get back to some of your current global
health initiatives.
But let's talk a little about the health care
law, because we're about to begin on October
1st open enrollment for six months.
And I'd like to give you a chance, first of
all, to tell them why -- when you took office,
we were teetering on the brink of a depression.
You had to avert it.
You had to start the recovery again.
Why in the midst of all this grief did you
also take on this complex issue?
Many people were saying, why doesn't he just
focus on the economy and leave this alone?
So tell us why you did it.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: Well, first of all, I think
it's important to remember that health care
is the economy.
A massive part of our economy.
And so the idea that somehow we can separate
out the two is a fallacy.
Second of all, the effort for us to deal with
a multifaceted health care crisis has been
going on for decades.
And the person who just introduced us, as
well as you, early in your presidency, had
as much to do with helping to shape the conversation
as anybody.
The fact is that we have been, up until recently,
the only advanced industrialized nation on
Earth that permits large numbers of its people
to languish without health insurance.
Not only is there the cruelty of people who
are unable to get health insurance having
to use the emergency room as their doctor
or their health service, but -- we're also
more efficient than anybody else and so when
we talk about, for example, our deficit -- you
know this better than anybody -- the reason
that we have not only current deficits but
also projected long-term deficits -- the structural
deficit that we have is primarily based on
the fact that we have a hugely inefficient,
wildly expensive health care system that does
not produce better outcomes.
And if we spent the same amount of money on
health care that Canada or France or Great
Britain did, or Japan, or any other industrialized
country, with the same outcomes or better
outcomes, that essentially would remove our
structural deficit, which would then free
up dollars for us to invest in early-childhood
education and infrastructure and medical research
and all the other things that can make sure
that we're competitive and growing rapidly
over the long term.
So my view when I came into office was we've
got an immediate crisis -- we've got to get
the economy growing.
But what we also have to do is to start tackling
some of these structural problems that had
been building up for years.
And one of the biggest structural problems
was health care.
It's what accounts for our deficit.
It's what accounts for our debt.
It causes pain and misery to millions of people
all across the country.
It is a huge burden on our businesses.
I was out at a Ford plant out in Missouri,
making the F series out there, and this is
a big stamping plant.
Ford is now the biggest seller in the United
States.
We took that lead back from the Japanese automakers.
But we are still burdened by the fact that
every U.S. automobile that is manufactured
requires a couple of thousand dollars in added
health care costs that our foreign competitors
don't have to pay.
So this has everything to do with the economy,
in addition to what I consider to be the moral
imperative that a mom should not have to go
bankrupt if her son or daughter gets sick;
that a family who's dealing with a layoff
and is already struggling to pay the bills
shouldn't also be wondering whether they're
one illness away from losing their home.
And I think most Americans agree with that.
(Applause.)
PRESIDENT CLINTON: So first of all, folks,
for those of you who are from the United States,
that's about as good an overview as you're
ever going to hear of what this economic issue
is.
But you remember the President said our structural
deficit would disappear if we had a comparable
health care system in terms of cost to the
French and Germans that are consistently rated
the highest.
It's about a trillion dollars a year, and
somewhere around 44 percent of that money
is government-funded money.
So you just run the numbers.
Think -- over half of our deficit has already
disappeared because of economic growth and
the revenues you raised and the spending we
cut.
And you pretty much get rid of the rest of
it if we just had a comparably expensive system
to any other country.
Before you took office, we lost a car company
that wanted to locate in Michigan that went
instead to Canada, and they announced -- they
said, look, we're a car company that provides
health care benefits to an employee, were
not a health care company that sells cars
to cover our bills.
We have to go to Canada.
And it was one of the few companies willing
to go on record and say this.
So thank you for doing it.
So let's talk about this.
What does this open enrollment mean?
How are people going to get involved?
When you have universal enrollment you can
manage your costs better and cut inflation
down.
I'll give the President a chance to talk about
all the good stuff that's happened, but I
just want you to know one thing.
In the last three years, just as we started
doing this, inflation in health care costs
has dropped to 4 percent for three years in
a row for the first time in 50 years.
Fifty years.
(Applause.)
Before that, the costs were going up at three
times the rate of inflation for a decade.
So now what?
What are you going to do on October 1st?
Tell them how this has got to work.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: Well, let me give folks just
a little bit of background about what's already
in place and then what happens on October
1st.
When we passed the Affordable Care Act, there
were a number of components to it.
A big part of it was essentially providing
a Patient's Bill of Rights that Americans
and advocates have been fighting for for decades.
So what we wanted to do was make sure if you
already have health insurance that you get
a fair deal, that you're being treated well
by your insurers.
So we eliminated, prohibited insurance companies
from imposing lifetime limits, which oftentimes
if a family member really got sick, they thought
they were covered until suddenly they hit
that limit and now they're out hundreds of
thousands of dollars with no way of paying.
We said to insurance companies, you've got
to use at least 80 percent of your premium
that you're receiving on actual health care
-- not on administrative costs and CEO bonuses.
And if you don't, you've got to rebate anything
that you spent back to the consumer.
So there are millions of Americans who've
received rebates.
They may not know that they got it because
of the Affordable Care Act -- or "Obamacare"
-- but they're pretty happy to get those rebates
back, because it made sure that the insurance
companies were treating folks fairly.
We said that any young person who doesn't
have health insurance can stay on their parent's
health insurance until they're 26 years old.
And as a consequence, what we've seen is steadily
the rate of uninsured for young people dropping
over the last three years since the bill passed
and obviously providing a lot of relief to
a lot of parents out there because a lot of
young people, as they've been entering into
the job market at a time when jobs are tough
to get and oftentimes benefits are slim, this
is providing enormous security until they
get more firmly established in the labor market.
We provided additional discounts for prescription
drugs for seniors under the Medicare program.
And so seniors have saved billions of dollars
when it comes to their prescription drugs.
So there have been over the last three years
a whole array of consumer protections and
savings for consumers that result directly
from the law that we passed.
And for those who say that they want to repeal
it, typically when you ask them about, what
are all these various benefits, they say,
well, that one is good, and that one is pretty
good, and we'd keep that.
And you pretty much go down the list, and
there's not too much people object to.
You will recall also at the time that part
of the way that we paid for the health care
bill was we said Medicare is wasting a lot
of money without making seniors healthier.
And there was a lot of hue and cry about how
we were taking money out of Medicare -- well,
it turns out that we were right, that we could
change how doctors and hospitals and providers
were operating, rewarding them for outcomes,
as opposed to simply how many procedures that
they did.
You started seeing practices change among
millions of providers across the country.
Medicare rates have actually slowed in terms
of inflation.
Seniors have saved money.
Folks are healthier.
And some of those savings we've been able
to use to make sure that people who don't
have health insurance get health insurance.
Now, this brings me to October 1st.
The one part of the Affordable Care Act that
required several years to set up, but a critical
part, was how do we provide health insurance
for individuals who don't get health insurance
through the job?
It's a historical accident that in this country
health care is attached to employers.
And part of the problem is if you're out there
shopping for health insurance on your own,
you're not part of a big pool, well, there's
no aggregation of risk taking place for the
insurers.
So they're basically going to say, let's see,
you're 50 years old.
You got high blood pressure.
And we just look at the actuarial tables and
we figure you're going to get sick, so we're
going to charge you $1,500 a month for health
insurance, which the average person has no
way of affording -- because there's no pooling
of risk.
So what we said was we need to set up a mechanism
to pool people who currently don't have health
insurance so that they have the same purchasing
power, the same leverage that a big companies
does when they're negotiating with the insurance
company.
And essentially what we've done is we've created
what we're calling marketplaces in every state
across the country where consumers are now
able to be part of a big pool.
Insurers have to bid, essentially compete
for the business of that pool.
And what we now have set up are these marketplaces
that provide high-quality health care at affordable
prices, giving people choices so that they
can get the health insurance that they need
and they want.
And the premiums are significantly lower than
what they were able to previously get.
I'll take the example of New York State.
The insurers put in their bids to participate
in these marketplaces.
It turns out that their rates are up to 50
percent lower than what was available previously
if you just went on the open market and you
tried to get health insurance.
(Applause.)
Fifty percent lower in this state.
California -- it's about 33 percent lower.
In my home state of Illinois, they just announced
it's about 25 percent lower.
So just by pooling and creating competition
so that insurers have to go after people's
business the way they go after a group plan,
we have drastically reduced premiums and costs.
On top of that, what we're now doing is we're
saying if with the better deal that you got
you still can't afford it, we're going to
give you tax credits to essentially subsidize
your purchase of health insurance.
And here's the net result.
We'll be continuing to roll out what the actual
prices are going to end up being, but I can
tell you right now that in many states across
the country, if you're, say, a 27-year-old
young woman, don't have health insurance,
you get on that exchange, you're going to
be able to purchase high-quality health insurance
for less than the cost of your cellphone bill.
And because all the insurers who participate
are required to, for example, provide free
preventive care, free contraceptive care,
that young woman, she may make up what she's
spending on premiums just on her monthly use
of health care.
So this is going to be a good deal for those
who don't have health insurance.
Those who already have health insurance get
better health insurance.
And the best part of the whole thing is, because
of these changes we initiated in terms of
how we're paying providers, health care costs
have grown, as you pointed out, Mr. President,
at the slowest rate in 50 years.
We are bending the cost curve and getting
at the problems that are creating our deficits
in Medicare and Medicaid.
(Applause.)
PRESIDENT CLINTON: I should point out that,
so far, in most states, one of the good things
that at least I didn't know whether it would
happen is when we began this in the United
States, more than 80 percent of the American
states had only one or two companies providing
health insurance who had more than 80 percent
of the market.
So there was, in effect, no price competition.
So what I was terrified of was we'd open these
things and there would only be one company
show up and bid, and this whole thing, we'd
be having an academic conversation.
Instead, it's actually led to the establishment
of more companies doing more bidding.
And I think part of it is they have greater
confidence that they can deliver health care
at a more modest cost.
So, so far, it's good.
But I think it's important for you to the
tell the people why we're doing all this outreach
-- because this only works, for example, if
young people show up.
And even if they buy their cheapest plan,
then they claim their tax credits, so it won't
cost them much -- 100 bucks a month or so.
We got to have them in the pools, because
otherwise all these projected low costs cannot
be held if older people with preexisting conditions
are disproportionately represented in any
given state.
You've got to have everybody lined up.
So explain what kind of -- all the work you've
been doing on the outreach for the opening
on October.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: I think President Clinton
makes a really important point.
And the way pools work, any pool, is essentially
those of us who are healthy subsidize somebody
who is sick at any given time.
We do that because we anticipate, well, at
some point we'll get sick and hope the healthy
person is in our pool so those costs and those
risks get spread.
That's what insurance is all about.
And what happens is if you don't have pools
that are a cross-section of society, then
people who are already sick or more likely
to get sick, they'll all rush out and buy
insurance.
People who are healthy, they say, you know
what, I won't bother.
And you get what's called adverse selection.
Essentially what happens is that the premiums
start going higher and higher because the
risks aren't spread broadly enough across
the population.
So you want to get a good cross-section in
every pool.
That's why big companies have an easier time
getting good rates for their employees than
small companies, because if you only have
five employees and one person is stricken
with breast cancer, let's say, your rates
potentially shoot up.
But if it's a thousand employees, then it
gets spread out.
So on October 1st, open enrollment begins.
All these folks can start signing up for the
marketplace.
And what we want to make sure of is that everybody,
in every category, in every age group, understands
why health insurance is important, understands
why they should sign up, understands the choices
that are going to be available to them.
They're going to be able to go to a computer,
tap on the web page and they're going to be
able to shop just like you shopped for an
airline ticket or a flat-screen TV, and see
what's the best price for you, what's the
plan that's best suited for you, and go ahead
and sign up right there and then.
And that the open enrollment period will last
from October 1st until the end of March and
so there will be six months for folks to sign
up.
Normally, this would be pretty straightforward.
A lot of people don't have health insurance.
A lot of people realize they should get health
insurance.
But let's face it, it's been a little political,
this whole Obamacare thing.
(Laughter.)
And so what you've had is an unprecedented
effort that you've seen ramp up over the last
month or so in which those who have opposed
the idea of universal health care in the first
place and have fought this thing tooth and
nail through Congress and through the courts
and so forth have been trying to scare and
discourage people from getting a good deal.
And some of you may have seen some of the
commercials out there that are a little whacky.
And the main message we have -- and we're
using social media, we're talking to churches,
we're talking to various civic groups -- and
what we're saying to people is, look, just
go to the website yourself.
Go to healthcare.gov; take a look at whether
this is a good deal or not and make your own
decision about whether this is good for you.
Because what we are confident about is that
when people look and see that they can get
high-quality, affordable health care for less
than their cell phone bill, they're going
to sign up.
They are going to sign up.
And part of what I think the resistance that
we've seen ramp up particularly over the last
couple of months is all about is the opponents
of health care reform know they're going to
sign up.
In fact, one of the major opponents, when
asked, well, why is it that you'd potentially
shut down the government at this point just
to block Obamacare, he basically fessed up.
He said, well, once consumers get hooked on
having health insurance and subsidies, then
they won't want to give it up.
(Laughter.)
I mean, that's -- you can look at the transcript.
This is one of the major opponents of health
care reform.
It is an odd logic.
Essentially they're saying people will like
this thing too much and then it will be really
hard to roll back.
So it is very important that people just know
what's out there, what's available to them,
and let people make up their own minds as
to whether it makes sense or not.
Now, one last thing I want to say, because
I do think sometimes -- people come up to
me and they say, well, if this is such a good
deal, how come the polls show that it's not
popular?
Well, one of the things you and I both know
is that when you come to health care, there's
no more personal and intimate decision for
people.
I mean, this is something that people really
care about.
And frankly, the devil you know is always
better than the devil you don't know.
And that's what "Harry and Louise" was all
about back in the '90s, right?
It was scaring people with the prospect of
change.
And so part of our goal here is just to make
sure people have good information.
And there has been billions of dollars spent
making people scared and worried about this
stuff.
And rather than trying to disabuse people
of every single bit of misinformation that's
been out there, what we're saying is just
look for yourself.
Take a look at it and you will discover that
this is a good deal for you.
PRESIDENT CLINTON: Well, first of all, I completely
agree with that.
I think we've got to just drive people to
the websites.
The states that are participating -- the Supreme
Court decision that upheld the health care
law said that states didn't have to set up
these marketplaces if they didn't want to,
but if they didn't the federal government
would set it up.
They also said that states didn't have to
expand Medicaid coverage to help people whose
incomes are up to 138 percent of the federal
poverty level buy health insurance.
There are some states, believe it or not,
that want the marketplace but don't want the
Medicaid.
And that's going to lead to a cruel result,
and there's nothing the President can do and
it's not his fault.
That's what the Supreme Court said.
So we can have this bizarre situation where,
let's say, a business with 60 employees can
-- or an individual going into the individual
market will get the benefit of tax credits
for everybody with incomes of 138 percent
of the federal poverty level or above, but
they won't get it for people who are between
100 and 138 percent.
So lower-income people who desperately need
the health insurance -- we would have the
cruelest of all situations in those states.
And there's nothing the President can do about
it because of the Supreme Court decision.
So we have to persuade the states to come
on.
But more and more states with Republican governors,
Republican legislatures are doing it.
Tell them about Arkansas, because we're doing
well down there.
(Laughter.)
PRESIDENT OBAMA: A little hometown bias, there's
nothing wrong with that.
(Laughter.)
A couple of things that are happening that
I think are very interesting.
First of all, look, I'm sympathetic to some
of these Republican governors who are under
a lot of pressure because the whole issue
of whether you're for Obamacare or not has
become a litmus test in the other party.
So some of them, politically it's been tough;
sometimes state legislatures that refuse to
allow governors to go ahead and implement.
But as you indicated, what we've seen is that
when Republican governors take a look at the
deal they're getting where, in addition to
these exchanges, we're also providing a much
more significant match, much more federal
money to provide health insurance -- from
the state's perspective, they're not paying;
the federal government is picking up the tab
-- and this is helping them because people
are no longer going to the emergency room
and they now have good health care, they're
now getting preventive care.
You're seeing some Republican governors step
up and saying, I may not like Obamacare, but
I'm going to go ahead and make sure that my
people are benefiting from this plan.
So that's one good thing that's happening.
The second thing that's happening is there
are a couple of states -- Arkansas is a good
example; Kentucky is another good example;
Idaho, interesting example -- these are states
where I just got beat.
I mean, I do not have a big constituency in
these states.
(Laughter.)
Well, I take that back.
You know what, 40 percent is still a lot of
people -- but I'm losing by 20 percent in
these states.
But the governors were still able to say we're
going to set up our own state exchanges, their
own marketplaces.
And each state is just using their own name
for it.
So I had a meet -- I had a conference, a video
conference with all the state directors of
all the marketplaces, and I'm talking to the
director in Kentucky and Idaho.
And in Kentucky, it's called like, Kentucky
Connect.
And in Idaho, it's called the Idaho Health
Care Exchange.
And there's a story that came out of Kentucky
where some folks were signing people up at
a county fair somewhere.
Some guy goes up and he starts looking at
the rates and decides he's going to sign up.
And he turns to his friend and said, this
is a great deal.
This is a lot better than Obamacare.
(Laughter.)
Right?
Which is fine.
(Laughter.)
Because we -- I don't have pride of authorship
on this thing.
I just want the thing to work.
And Arkansas just came out with its rates,
and as has been true in virtually every single
state, not only are premiums lower than they
were, they're a lot lower than even the most
optimistic predictions were about how low
they would be.
And once these marketplaces are up and running,
it turns out that what has traditionally been
a pretty conservative principle, which is
competition and choice work, well, in the
insurance market, competition and choice work.
And what we're seeing is that people are going
to be able to get the kind of health care
that they have never been able to get before.
States are going to benefit from it because
they're going to save money.
And one thing that all of you -- there are
probably very few people in this room who
don't have health insurance, although if you
don't, you should sign up starting on October
1st.
(Laughter.)
One of the things that many people don't realize
is that the subsidy that all of you provide
for the uninsured is about $1,000 per family.
You pay $1,000 -- everybody here who has got
health insurance pays about $1,000 more for
your families' insurance than you otherwise
would have, because hospitals are mandated,
they are required to provide service to anybody
who shows up.
And so what happens is when you've got 15
percent of the population without health insurance,
they end up showing up at the emergency room
typically at a point when they're much sicker
than if they had been getting regular checkups
and preventive care.
So you pay for the most expensive care there
is, because hospitals have got to recoup that
money somewhere.
And the way they do it is to charge higher
prices.
And people who have health insurance end up
picking it up.
So part of what will help reduce the increase
in health care costs is making sure that that
hidden subsidy no longer exists.
PRESIDENT CLINTON: Let's talk a little bit
about business, because we're out of time,
but I think it's really important.
As you pointed out, most people who have insurance
work for a living, or somebody in their family
does, and they get their insurance through
their workplace.
The law says that all employers have to participate
if they have 50 employees or more.
Many employers with fewer than 50 employees
already voluntarily provide some health insurance.
Both the companies with 50 or more and the
companies with fewer than 50 are somewhat
concerned.
And the employees that have to be insured
are those who work 30 hours a week or more.
So there were many people who speculated that
when this law came into place that it would
add to the cost and there would be a lot more
part-time workers instead of full-time workers.
I'll save the President the time in the interview
on this -- so far, that's not true.
The overwhelming number of people who have
been hired coming out of this recession have
been -- they have been hired at lower wages,
but they have been full-time employees.
There has not been an increase in the percentage
of our employment in part-time work.
There has been an increase in relatively lower-wage
new jobs.
But that means they need health insurance
even more.
So explain very briefly to them how this is
going to work, how private employers are helped
to buy their insurance and the requirements.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: Well, first of all, if you're
a large employer or an employer with more
than 50 employees, you're already providing
health insurance, you don't have to do anything
other than just make sure that you can show
that you're providing health insurance.
And there was a lot of news recently about
how we delayed the so-called employer mandate
for a year -- because under the law, what
it says is if you have more than 50 employees,
you're not providing health insurance to your
employees, then you're going to pay a penalty
to help pay for the fact that we, the taxpayers,
are going to have to provide your employees
with health insurance -- which, by the way,
is only fair.
A lot of the controversy around the Affordable
Care Act had to do with these so-called mandates,
both an employer mandate and an individual
mandate.
And the employer mandate says, if you don't
meet your responsibilities by your employees,
and they end up getting Medicaid or they're
ending up in the emergency room, you're basically
dumping those costs onto society.
That's not fair.
So we're going to charge you a couple thousand
dollars to help pay for health care for those
employees.
To the individuals, what we said was we're
going to make health insurance so affordable,
so cheap for you, so heavily subsidized if
you're not making a lot of money, that if
you're not getting health insurance then it's
because you just decided you don't want to,
you don't need to.
And in that circumstance, what happens when
you get hit by a bus, heaven forbid, or somebody
in your family gets sick, and you hadn't had
them covered?
Well, we're going to end up having to pay
for you anyway because we're not going to
just let somebody bleed in front of the emergency
room.
So what we've said is you've got to take responsibility,
and so there's a small penalty if you don't
get health insurance.
This is where a lot of the controversy and
unpopularity came in, because people generally
don't like to be told, "you've got to get
health insurance," and employers don't like
be told, "you've got to give your employees
health insurance."
But, as a society, what we cannot do is to
say, you have no responsibilities whatsoever,
but you've got guaranteed coverage.
And this raises the whole issue of preexisting
conditions, which we haven't talked a lot
about but is really important.
One of the central components of this law,
one of the main perversities of the health
care system before this law passed was there
were millions of people around the country
who, if you had gotten sick before, if you
had had a heart attack, if you had had cancer,
if you had diabetes; let's say, when it first
happened you had a job, you got cured; then
you lose your job or you're trying to change
jobs or you're trying to start a business,
you try to go out and get health insurance,
the health insurance company not only could
deny you but had every incentive to deny you.
Because, basically, they'd rather have healthy
people who are paying premiums and never asking
for a payout.
They don't want somebody who actuarially they
can anticipate might get sick.
And so, keep in mind that a huge percentage
of our society has some sort of preexisting
condition, and they can be locked out.
You can do everything right, work hard, build
a strong middle-class life, but if you've
been sick and then you lose your job or something
happens, you may suddenly be locked out of
the insurance market, or the premiums may
be so high that only somebody fabulously rich
could afford it.
So what we said is, all right, you know what,
insurance companies, you can no longer bar
somebody from getting health insurance just
because they've got a preexisting condition.
But the only way that works is if everybody
had a requirement to get health insurance.
Because think about what happens if you don't
have that rule.
Well, all of us -- not all of us, but a lot
of us who were trying to figure out how to
save some money would say, well, I'm not going
to worry about it until I get sick, and then
right when I'm diagnosed with something that's
going to be expensive I'll go to the insurance
company and say, you can't prevent me from
getting health insurance just because I've
got a preexisting condition.
So they could potentially game the system
and it wouldn't work.
So now what we've done is said you've got
to provide health insurance to anybody, all
comers -- that's the deal.
The flipside of it is everybody has got some
responsibility and we'll help you pay for
it to get health insurance.
And that's where a lot of the misunderstandings,
the frustrations about health care reform
came in.
I should add, by the way, that this was the
same proposition that was set up in Massachusetts
under a governor named Mitt Romney that's
working really well.
Ninety-nine percent of the people in Massachusetts
have coverage.
And that same principle was, ironically, considered
a very smart Republican conservative principle.
But it was the right one.
The economics of it are true.
So, just to finish up the question, when it
comes to businesses, if you're already providing
health insurance for your employees, that's
great.
You don't have do much other than just make
sure that you show us that you've got health
insurance for your employees.
If you have more than 50 employees, and you're
not providing health insurance for them, you
now have the opportunity to join a pool of
small businesses to get a better price and
a better deal on health insurance.
You're eligible for tax credits in providing
health insurance to your employees.
Up to 35 percent of the premiums for each
employee will be a tax benefit -- a tax credit
from the federal government.
But if you still aren't providing health insurance
for your employees after that, then we're
going to go ahead and penalize you for it.
And I can understand why some businesses wouldn't
want to pay for it.
If they're not currently providing health
insurance for their employees, what that means
is that they'd rather have those additional
profits than make sure that their employees
are getting a fair deal.
In some cases, they may be operating under
some very small margins.
But keep in mind, since people are -- companies
are exempted, the average small business with
five employees, mom-and-pop shop, 10 employees,
they're not under that requirement.
So I'm not that sympathetic to a company,
typically, if it's got more than 50 employees
and generating some significant revenue, we're
making it affordable for them to provide health
insurance for their employees.
They should do the right thing.
(Applause.)
PRESIDENT CLINTON: I agree with that.
We have to close, but I think there's one
last issue we ought to deal with.
The most important thing obviously is just
to get people enrolled in this.
We'll work through it as we go along.
But you just heard the President say that
so far in virtually every state, the actual
prices of the insurance are coming in quite
a bit lower than they were originally estimated
to.
With the original price estimates and with
the government obligated to provide subsidies
-- which costs money on the budget, right?
-- it was, nonetheless, estimated that in
the first 10 years, this would keep the national
debt $110 billion lower than it otherwise
would have been, which means if we come in
at even less, we can bring the debt down more,
or we can subsidize more small businesses
and get more small businesses into this loop.
A lot of people come up to me and say, now,
you sound like the people you used to criticize
who say we could cut taxes all day long, increase
spending and balance the budget.
Don't give me that; this sounds too good to
be true.
So I think before you leave, you should tell
people how we can spend more -- not so much
in direct spending, but in tax credits -- and
still wind up reducing overall federal spending
by $110 billion during this decade.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: Well, a couple of things
just in terms of how this whole thing got
paid for.
First of all, I think it's really important
to point out here that the total cost of the
Affordable Care Act to provide health insurance
for every American out there at an affordable
rate is costing about the same amount over
the course of 10 years as the cost of the
prescription drug bill that President Bush
passed -- except that wasn't paid for.
We felt obliged to actually pay for it and
not just add to the deficit.
(Applause.)
So what we did -- it's paid for by a combination
of things.
We did raise taxes on some things.
We, for example, said that for high-end income
individuals, you can pay a slightly higher
Medicare rate -- Medicare tax.
So we bumped that up a little bit.
We said that for employers who are currently
providing a so-called Cadillac health care
plan, where there are so many bells and whistles,
there's no incentive to actually spend wisely
when it comes to health care -- we're actually
going to penalize you for that -- not only
to raise a little bit of money, but also to
say you're encouraging the worst aspects of
a health care system where you spend a lot
of money, you don't get better outcomes.
I mentioned to you Medicare.
We basically said -- there's a program in
Medicare called Medicare Advantage that provides
some additional options for Medicare recipients
above and beyond standard Medicare.
And it's very popular with a lot of seniors.
You get eyeglasses and other benefits.
But it turned out that it was so uncompetitive
that we were providing tens of billions of
dollars of subsidies to the insurance companies
under this Medicare Advantage Plan without
getting better outcomes, health outcomes for
seniors.
So what we said was we'll keep Medicare Advantage
and we'll give them a small premium if they're
providing better services for seniors, but
we're going to make you compete for it a little
bit.
And we're going to save tens of billions of
dollars in the process, and that will go into
paying for the Affordable Care Act.
So the bottom line is, through these various
mechanisms we raised enough money to pay for
providing health insurance for those who don't
have it, to provide these tax credits in the
marketplace, and at the same time, because
we're driving down costs, we actually end
up saving a little money.
It is a net reduction of our deficit.
The irony of those who are talking about repealing
Obamacare because it's so wildly expensive
is if they actually repealed the law, it would
add to the deficit.
It would add to the deficit.
Now, there have been a couple of Republicans
in the House who have been smart enough to
say, we're going to repeal all the benefits
so that 25, 30 million people don't get health
insurance, but we're going to keep the taxes
that Obama raised, we just won't talk about
that.
And then, that way we can say we reduced the
deficit.
But obviously, you're doing some funny business
there with the budget.
But, look, nothing is free.
The bottom line, though, is do we want to
continue to live in a society where we've
got the most inefficient health care system
on Earth, leaving millions of people exposed
to the possibilities that they could lose
everything because they get sick?
Or we've got little children and families
going to the emergency room once a week because
they've got asthma and other preventable diseases,
because their families aren't linked up with
a primary care physician who is providing
them regular care?
Where the costs to society for reduced productivity,
illnesses, et cetera, all burden our businesses?
Is that the kind of society we aspire to?
And I think the answer is no.
And the notion that we would resist, or at
least some would resist as fiercely as they
have, make this their number-one agenda, perpetuating
a system in which millions of people across
the country, hardworking Americans don't have
access to health care I think is wrong.
(Applause.)
PRESIDENT CLINTON: We have to close.
But I will close with a story.
I told you all this morning that the employee
that our health access program lost in the
Kenya mall shooting was a Dutch nurse.
And we spend a lot of time in the Netherlands;
we get a lot of support there.
Oxi is one of the biggest insurance companies
in Europe.
They're one of our partners here.
I went to celebrate their 200th anniversary
with them.
They started as a fire insurance company with
39 farmers, 200 years ago.
And we were out there in this big farm field
in a tent in the shadow of a 13th century
church and a big Dutch windmill.
And I asked the chairman of the company, I
said, do you write health insurance?
Because in the Netherlands there's no Medicare
and no Medicaid, everybody is on an individual
mandate and you just subsidize people based
on their incomes.
He said, yes, I write it; we all do.
And he looked at me and he said, but we don't
make any money on it.
And he said, we shouldn't.
This guy is running a huge -- can you imagine
somebody saying that in America?
(Laughter.)
He said, we shouldn't.
If I can't make money on this business doing
traditional insurance business, I've got no
business in the work.
He said, look, health care is a public good
and you've got to find a way to finance it
for everybody.
(Applause.)
And he said, it's just an intermediary function
that somebody has to handle.
But in the end, it's how it's delivered, how
it's priced, and how healthy you can keep
your people.
So the First Lady is trying to keep us all
healthier, and you're trying to change the
delivery and the pricing.
And you have to cover everybody to do it.
I think this is a big step forward for America.
This will, over the next decade, not only
make us healthier, but it will free up in
the private sector largely funds that can
then be reinvested in other areas of economic
growth, and give us a much more well-balanced
economy.
But, first, we've got to get everybody to
sign up.
PRESIDENT OBAMA: Everybody, sign up.
Go to healthcare.gov.
Thank you very much.
(Applause.)